– Ich weiß, Sie ärgern sich über
den neuen Termin.
Ja, wenn es gut werden soll,
dann dauert es eben manchmal
’n bisschen länger.
Aber das Warten lohnt sich ja dann auch.
Sie müssen mich auch verstehen.
Nein.
Okay, müssen Sie nicht.
Aber bitte, regen Sie sich nicht so auf.
Wir kriegen das schon hin!
Die neue Deadline steht.
Danke,
vielen Dank!
Oh, ich werd wahnsinnig.
Hallo, Pepe González.
Herr Al-Pascha!
Ich freu mich, Sie zu hören.
Sie haben den Job, seit zwei Wochen?
Ja, großartig! Das wundert mich aber
nicht. Sie waren sehr gut vorbereitet.
Natürlich, sehr gern, jederzeit wieder.
Ach, Herr Al-Pascha, das ist ja witzig,
ich seh hier grad Ihre Tochter mit
meinem Bruder im Park.
Soll ich die beiden Turteltauben
mal von Ihnen grüßen?
Da wären sie bestimmt überrascht.
Ja natürlich, wir hören uns.
In Ordnung. Bis später und alles Gute!
– Ist die Höhe gut?
– Ja, perfekt!
Eine Sekunde ...
Oh nein!
– Was ist?